watch easy of it have you ever tried to
roll over a thousand pound unconscious
elephant seal I hadn't either take it
from me it's not easy I'm Wes Larson a
wildlife biologist and lover of the
outdoors for as long as I can remember
I'm traveling the country to find the
next generation of conservationists the
people on the front lines of the fight
to understand our planet and protect the
animals we share it with this time
around I'm on the west coast
just north of Monterey Bay I'm meeting
up with an elephant seal research team
at the University of California Santa
Cruz Rachael Holzer has been studying
elephant seals of the coastal at for
four years and believes tracking
elephant seals could hold the key to a
deeper understanding of the ocean as a
whole
our mission this morning is to attach
some high-tech tracking tags to an
elephant seal
but not just any seal will do we are a
little bit particular about the animals
we put satellite tags on so an adult
female over 4 years old and under 13
years old hasn't been tracked before and
has been on the beach for nearly a month
in short they're looking for a seal that
has had her pup and is ready to head
back out into the sea Rachel tells me
that there are seven promising
candidates on the beach today which
sounds like a lot to me but then I see
the colony for the first time we just
kind of rounded this hill and suddenly
all these seals are spread out in front
of us one thing that's super surprising
is the amount of vocalization that's
going on all the seals kind of talking
to each other out here it's a lot to
take in the seals are big loud
absolutely cover the beach take by nose
take a recite native book for sure yeah
we'll see what we can find the
researchers are fanning out there just
go and seal the seal trying to find the
particular female that they're trying to
tag today with a couple thousand seals
on the beach it's like looking for a
needle and a very noisy and potentially
dangerous
haystack but it's worth the risk turns
out if you want to study the farthest
reaches of the ocean elephant seals are
natural deep-sea explorers they go way
out into the middle of the North Pacific
and they dive far deeper than anybody
thought was possible
and eventually Rachel spots the perfect
seal you're looking straight down
there's two animals back-to-back one has
a pup nursing on her right side I think
that that is her we had a good look at
her so we're estimating her mass at
about 340 kilograms so we're gonna pull
up a 3.4 CC dose of Teela's all and so
you physically just go up and put the
needle in them yep
that is how this goes it's a big meal
that's to get through all that blubber
yeah exactly
there's a big male over there it's
actually the alpha male of this colony
so we're kind of just waiting for them
to get positioned in a way to where the
researchers can go in sedate the seal
and then attach their tag this is the
most dangerous part of the research
rachel has to inject the sedative by
hand and elephant seals can be
unpredictable they are very dangerous
animals I know they look pretty lazy and
sleepy if they're on a beach but they
can move surprisingly quickly and react
surprisingly quickly and the big guys
you know the males are almost two tonnes
and they can run as fast as a person can
run we spend years being trained to work
with them properly did you get the seal
stuck just keep a light hand on her nose
just in case she she pulls that again
there's like a bunch of different things
going on right now it's pretty
impressive Theresa's taking these
ultrasound measurements with the blubber
these two collaborators are putting on
the epoxy for this tag that we're
attaching to get that oceanographic data
and then on top and we're also attaching
a VHF tag Rachel's kind of organizing
everyone and directing everyone to do
with their
meanwhile as always we have all these
other seals that we kind of always have
to be keeping an eye on to make sure
that no one's coming up in a aggresively
kind of challenging the group Thank You
Patrick
we've been monitoring the population in
ano nuevo for between three and four
decades now if the elephant seals are
not doing well that means that something
is really going sideways down in the
food web
we got another seal kind of creeping
back here alright so yeah one of the
really cool things about these tags is
they're actually recording oceanographic
information like that all sorts of
things that they would normally record
with like a really expensive research
vessel they're using these seals kind of
has that research vessel and elephant
seals make exceptionally good research
vessels after they leave the colony they
swim out into the Pacific for thousands
of miles diving over a mile below the
surface and all the while the tags will
be collecting data but you end up with
is a three dimensional profile of the
ocean that is if all goes as planned
it's just so crazy to have like this
happening 20 feet away and be away as
we're working on this eel at times that
reminded me of being in an ER at others
was like being on another planet
surrounded by hostile worlds
one thing that's really interesting is
this kind of like Matador act they have
going on its are going to come through
at all points we have to be ready to
kind of back off right away
if one of these sales process through
the chaos the team gets it done two
point three different tax and giving the
seal of full checkup alright okay go
ahead good so far so good with the
science complete there's one important
step left waiting for our seal to wake
up we'll stay nearby so that if a male
decides to try and make with her we can
prevent it we're fully responsible for
the well-being of the animal until she
is capable of taking care of herself so
it looks like our females doing really
well she's recovering nicely she's moved
back into the group and hopefully in
about three days she'll head off to sea
and give us lots of the awesome data
looking out at the colony it's hard to
imagine that a hundred years ago
elephant seals nearly disappeared they
did almost go extinct back in the early
1900s
once the seal was protected and hunting
was no longer permitted they rebounded
and they have been spreading ever since
and now you guys are using them in all
these kind of new novel ways to learn
more about the ocean to protect other
species yeah absolutely
I found that conservation success can
sometimes be as simple as changing
perceptions Rachel and her team have
shown that an animal that appears to dis
liya round on a beach is actually an
incredible traveler an athlete and by
harnessing their power we are able to
gain a deeper understanding of the ocean
it makes me wonder how else we could be
working with wildlife to protect the
planet that we all share
[Music]
[Music]